did you ever wonder what would happen if
the strongest Marines became Pirates how
would their pirate Crews look and how
strong would they be is there anyone
among them who could become the next
king of the pirates for example kizu the
scariest of the three current Admirals
would be just as if not even scarier as
a pirate imagine if he didn't have to
listen to the celestial dragons and the
higher ups and could do whatever he
wanted first of all I think it's safe to
assume that he would still eat the Pika
Pik noi at some point is that had
nothing to do with him being a marine of
course before venturing out to the Sea
kiz would need to assemble a crew
because without them there would be no
one to remind him how denden Mushi work
and on top of that I honestly doubt he
could navigate the Seas by himself now
just to be clear in this video we'll not
be exploring what would happen if these
marines became Pirates today but rather
what would happen if they chose to
become pirates in the first place when
they were still young anyway while
sailing kiz would usually act relaxed
and like he doesn't care much about
anything around him however that would
quickly change if someone anchors him
enough this happened once in the show
after he failed to eliminate the straw
hat Pirates and went on a rampage
capturing every pirate on the island
during sa Arc knowing how cocky the
majority of the Pirates are sooner or
later one of them will do something
that'll seriously annoy Kiza and at that
point every pirate in his vicinity is
doomed with his Pika P noi kizu would
quickly go from ship to ship and Destroy
even the large fleets all by himself
this unprecedented strength would
quickly make kizu famous throughout the
ground line and everyone would know not
to mess with him it sounds a bit weird
but I think that he would be really
similar to mihawk a strong guy who just
Minds his own business on his own
territory and doesn't really involve
himself with politics or stuff like that
and while we're talking about kizu
similarities to mihawk it's also likely
he would become a warlord however he
wouldn't do this so he could commit
crimes without having to worry about
Marines but more because he doesn't want
to be bothered while traveling at the
end of the day I just don't see kizu
having any ambitious goals or going out
of his way to search for the one piece
so he'd probably just retire from piracy
after becoming an old man and live out
his remaining years in peace similar to
ter this was only the first out of seven
characters we're covering in this video
and some of them will be much stronger
than kizu anyway I think we can all
agree kizu just wouldn't fit as the next
pirate king and there's someone else
who's way more fitting for the role
someone much fre of course I'm talking
about Monkey D GARP being Luffy's
Grandpa GARP shares the same easygoing
attitude as him also in one of the
prototypes for the first chapter of One
Piece instead of Shanks GARP is the
famous pirate who inspires Luffy to go
on his Adventure this means that even
Oda the creator of One Piece thought
GARP could make an excellent pirate so
what would this guy do if he switch jobs
well first of all we can all agree that
his pirate crep would look really
similar to Luffy's he would most likely
only have a handful of crew mates who
would all consider each other friends
and would even die for one another now
since Bogart is garp's right-hand man in
the show it's only natural that he would
be the Vice Captain of garp's crew and
the man he trusts the most GARP would
gladly help anyone in need on his
journeys and would prioritize the most
fun path instead of the most optimal
boring one however one way he would
differ from Luffy is that GARP really
enjoys training wimps and turning them
into capable Fighters as he did with
Kobe and helmo in the show based on this
we can assume that GAR would have a
couple of youngsters on his crew at all
times similar to how Roger had Shanks
and buggy in his crew he would
constantly overtrain these poor
youngsters making them repeatedly punch
the Subscribe button with their bare
hands which you should also try by the
way and leaving them in dangerous areas
to survive but they would love and
respect him regardless of course his
rivalry with Roger would still stay and
I can imagine the two fighting to death
one day then partying and drinking the
next let's be honest GARP always really
respected Roger but just couldn't be
friendly with him because he was a
pirate so now that they're both Pirates
they can finally be buddies same as
Roger GARP would also want to find the
legendary treasure one piece but knowing
his Carefree attitude he would often get
distracted by random adventures and
spend too much time having fun on
various Islands so even in this timeline
I still believe Roger would be the one
to eventually find the treasure and he
would probably tell GARP all about it
same as he did to Whitebeard in the
original story from this point on GARP
and his crew would sail the Seas for
many many years and the great pirate
GARP would eventually die a piece of old
age surrounded by friends and companions
okay although Garb didn't become the
king of the Pirates he at least had a
fun Journey with his friends but we
can't say the same for the next
character on the list whose Journey
ended much more tragically you see
greenbull is one of the new Admirals
introduced after the time Skip and
although we know very little about him
we know he really likes to idolize
people and act like them we've seen this
in the show with his admiration towards
the fleet Admiral sakazuki with
greenbull even adopting a really similar
Justice motto as him so if he was to
become a pirate I'm certain he would do
something similar and idolize some
famous evil pirate like kaido or big mom
with this attitude greenb would go
around causing a bunch of trouble for
everyone destroying towns and maybe even
whole islands in the process in the
anime we also know that green bow likes
to prove his strength to those he
admires which is why despite sakazuki
telling him not to he went to wano in
order to capture Luffy thinking sakazuki
would be pleased if he succeeds he would
be no different as a pirate and would
probably be the cockiest out of everyone
on this list he would create a crew full
of people like him who think they could
take down the absolute strongest in the
world but this is precisely the reason I
don't believe his Adventure would go the
way he wants you see with this attitude
greenow would carelessly charge into an
Emperor's territory like hake island
wano or maybe even some of the
whitebeard's territory of course he
wouldn't have any solid plan set in
place and would just go to prove himself
by killing someone strong and as you can
probably guess he would be completely
completely obliterated I can only see
three possible outcomes for greenbull
after this loss he would either be dead
captured in big bomb's book or
imprisoned in kaido's prison on wano I
think it's best for this guy to just
stick to being a marine now although all
the characters we covered so far had no
intentions of actually becoming the
Pirates in the story this next one
actually did become a pirate needless to
say I'm talking about aliji the new
Titanic commander of the Blackbeard
Pirates so did you ever wonder how
different his pirate career would turn
out if he was a pirate from the very
beginning well first ly he would be a
bit weaker than in the original story as
he would never meet GARP and train with
him of course he would still become
incredibly strong by training alone but
we can all agree that nothing can really
replace garps on Orthodox training
methods another important thing is that
Nico Robin wouldn't have survived the
ohada incident because there'd be no one
to save her I mean I don't think I like
this scenario so far if AI G was a
pirate I believe he'd be laidback not
worrying about some race for an ancient
treasure he also wouldn't hurt innocent
citizens or forcefully take any
territories he would just chill also I
think alij G would be the first
character on the list who wouldn't have
a single crewmate for him having a crew
is just having people he has to worry
about and protect and that's not
something he wants to do being alone
also gives him the freedom to travel
however and whenever he wants so there's
no one to scream at him for lazing
around and sleeping all the time on the
rare instances that he does decide to
wake up and travel he would do it by
freezing the water with his hiahia no me
and riding his signature bicycle over it
no need for a fancy ship although ALG
would be pretty strong he could never be
become an emperor have a high Bounty
that's because the world government
would never view him as a serious threat
since he doesn't cause any problems for
them and he doesn't even have a crew to
begin with due to his lack of any goal
and crew after a few years I can totally
see him joining someone else's pirate
crew like he did in the original story
however he wouldn't join just any crew
it has to be the one aliji agrees with
and of course they have to let him still
be a free man without too many
responsibilities this could very well be
garp's crew since they could probably
get along as pirates the same way they
did as Marines also obviously wouldn't
be that strict about discipline which is
great for aliji from here on he would
sail the Seas along with GARP and would
help him train the youngsters on the
ship there's still three incredibly
strong Marines left to cover and you
won't believe how strong the last one
would be as a pirate sokku senku is a
tough one to predict his position is the
fleet Admiral forced him to listen to
all orders from above so we don't really
know much about his personal views one
thing we know for sure is that he at
least is not as rotten as some of the
other people in the Navy since zoku was
keen on adopting and training kids in
the past like rosinante and ex Drake we
can expect that as a pirate he would do
something similar just on a much bigger
level since he wouldn't have to do it in
secret anymore soku would adopt and
raise kids he sees potential in and
would turn them into top tier Fighters
while everyone else we've covered so far
would either have a small crew or no
crew at all sangoku would actually have
a giant Fleet it would partly be made
out of the kids he's trained but a big
chunk would also be random Pirates who
would join him out of respect okay but
what would he actually do with this
giant Fleet well sangoku does have any
world domination goals or anything like
that in mind he just want to get to the
one piece just like everyone else but he
wouldn't rush it I mean his whole thing
is that he's the strategist so he would
probably have a big step-by-step plan on
how to locate all the poneglyphs how to
steal them and so on discipline would be
the key in this crew and sangoku would
often punish people who don't listen to
him or slack off however his crew mates
would still respect him because they
know that everything he does is for
their own safety sangoku would value his
men a lot and would always try to
minimize his crew's deaths and injuries
he would be careful careful about who he
sends to combat and would avoid any
unnecessary disputes with Marines and
other Pirates he would also be on good
terms with most of the strongest Pirates
like Roger and Whitebeard and although
they wouldn't exactly be buddies they
wouldn't bother each other due to his
mighty Fleet and very good strategy
sangoku and his crew would be one of the
main players in the race for the one
piece but would they actually manage to
claim it before Roger well no you see
Roger has done a lot of stupid and not
fully thought out things during his
journey like riding the knockup stream
to arrive on skypia or sneaking into big
mom's territory to get the poneglyph
given how tactical sangoku is it doesn't
really seem likely that he would take
all these risks and would probably just
think of other safer ways to do these
things however even though Roger would
still become the pirate king in this
timeline sangoku would be remembered as
one of the legends of the era and who
knows he may even become the emperor at
some point before we explain how will
sakazuki the strongest current marine
officer far as a pirate let's first
cover someone completely different
someone who has absolutely no desire to
achieve titles or find treasures fujit
tor although fujit TOA may be the least
scary out of the three Admirals he is by
no means a weakling we all know that
Fuji TOA blinded himself because he
couldn't stand looking at the evil
anymore now considering how much evil
the world government does it's not hard
to imagine that in this fictional
timeline fujit too would see something
so bad that they did which would
eventually lead him to become a pirate
to oppose the evil government however
even after becoming a pirate I believe
he would still be one of the good guys
and would try to use his influence as a
pirate to make the world a better place
actually when you think about it by not
being awn to the Marines he could
probably do much more good than he
currently can in the story his goals as
a pirate would be to completely change
the current power system in the world
and free people from the world
government's control due to their
similar goals fujit too would often work
with dragon in the Revolutionary Army
being one of their biggest allies when
he's not helping them however he would
sail around the grand line freeing
islands that are controlled by evil
people and protecting them from Pirates
he would offer those people to join his
crew guing them protection as long as
they stick to him similar to what Shanks
is doing with all those weak Crews
sailing with him he would donate most of
the money he steals from other Pirates
to the islands that needed the most and
would overall be well-respected and a
liked pirate and finally let's talk
about a character you've all been
waiting for the current Fleet Admiral
Akainu as a pirate Akainu would
definitely be one of the worst Pirates
maybe even the worst he's already pretty
violent as a marine so just imagine how
Troublesome he would be if he didn't
have to listen to any orders now combine
his unstable character with super
destructive mug no me and you get an
absolute monster of a pirate a kind who
would command a gigantic pirate ship and
have a very large crew under his command
judging by his character he wouldn't
consider his crew mates friends and
would see them more as pawns that he can
use to achieve his goals it's likely
that he would even kill his own men if
they ever did something to displease him
also any pirate alliances are completely
out of the question is a kind who would
rather die fighting than Ally himself
with another pirate same as all strong
Pirates AK would have many territories
under him that would in return for his
protection before to give him large
amounts of money every single month AK
would be one of the most feared pirate
captains in the new world annihilating
smaller pirate Crews he comes across or
sparing them if they chose to work under
him of course he wouldn't only attack
the weak Pirates but would also
frequently fight other Marine Admirals
and Emperors easily matching their
strength and when most of his men die he
would just Recruit new people from
territories under his control
replenishing his forces over and over
again now you probably noticed that ainu
as a pirate would share a lot of
similarities with kaido but what if I
tell you that he would actually be way
more dangerous than him for one simple
reason you see unlike kaido a kaido
wouldn't just sit on one Island and
slowly grow his army and would instead
be constantly fighting everyone around
him conquering even more territories and
bringing Terror everywhere he goes
although Aku and his pirate crew may
seem Unstoppable and strong enough to
find the one piece this attitude would
eventually lead to their downfall you
see when you make the entire world your
enemy and refuse to negotiate or back
down the world might just team up to
take you down I mean just ask roxs he
knows it all too well in this scenario
it's most likely that a big alliance
between Pirates would eventually form
with the sole goal of defeating a since
he also enraged the Marines with his
senseless destruction they would also
help the pirate Alliance behind the
scenes providing them with weapons or
money despite all of his power there
wouldn't be anything a Kyu could do and
after a long battle he would finally be
killed by the Pirates since you
obviously love these what if videos you
can click on this video next where we
explain how strong will each Straw Hat
be at the end of the series and trust me
some of these powerups are insane